this person i forget what their name is
so i'm going to call them
smithers
yeah okay smithers yeah so smithers
wanted to go out to the midnight
premiere of harry potter and the goblet
of fire and invited me and we were going
to make it like a date and i dumb name
smithers yeah so smithers really wanted
me to come along to this and i really
wanted to go but you know i had a very
strict bedtime you know 10 o'clock and
i'm in bed and i can't go out so i
planned it perfectly that i was going to
sneak out and go to this movie premiere
and i went to bed i waited to hear my
dad and my stepmom go to bed i slept in
my bed with my clothes on because i was
ready and so i
when the time comes and i hear them
close the door and all the it's quiet
for a while i slowly get out of bed you
know it's squeaking but i'm like being
real careful about it and like i'm
tiptoeing as carefully as i can and
before i left just in case they came in
my room and were wondering where i was i
left a little note i'll come back to
that note later because it's
it's important but
like i'll get it at the end so i sneak
out of the house and i don't go out the
front door i go out the back door it's
not like our doors had like bb beep
alarms or anything but i just thought
the front door was not sneaky enough oh
too obvious yeah yeah too obvious sure
right sure so i sneak out the back we
have a sliding door in the back and it
also is like way squeakier and way
louder you know how sliding doors are
when they're old and they got dirt in
there
it's like an earthquake yeah exactly i
sneak out the back and i creep around
the side but i don't go around the side
where my my parents bedroom is because
they could see me even though there's no
windows that look out the side yard
when i actually got that way i went
around the other way through the gravel
the very loud crunchy gravel
so i sneak out the side and i get in the
car and for some reason my dumb ass you
know didn't put it in neutral and like
roll it out of the driveway no i just
turned that baby on in the driveway and
then i flipped the lights for some
reason like just blasting the house with
lights i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i waited a few minutes in the car
like i was waiting for the comical like
light in my parents bedroom to turn on
so sneaky then i roll the car out of the
driveway and i drive to the movie
theater and at this point i had taken so
long to get out of the house so i get to
the movie theater and there's no line or
nothing it's like because everyone's in
the theater watching the movie and so i
didn't know where they were i don't
think i had a cell phone at this point
so i couldn't text them and say hey i'm
here which theater are you in so what i
did was i poked my head in every single
one of the theaters
leaned over and just kind of scanned the
crowd for a bit and like people were
like looking at me all shifty like what
the [ __ ] is going on with this guy and
i'm like where are you s smithers
where are you and so not that theater so
i go over to the next theater the dumb
name and i'm catching like snippets of
harry potter as i go into like the rooms
one at a time
and i go into every single movie theater
and i could not find smithers no matter
how hard i looked and at that point it
got so far into the movie that i was
just like man i'm missing out on the
movie so i just
went into a random ass theater and just
sat in one of the handicapped seats and
i was like i might as well watch it i'm
here so i watched the movie smithers was
nowhere to be seen so i go back into my
car and i'm like scanning around and i
wait until everyone leaves the parking
lot and i'm like oh god
they're not here i'm all alone
i drive back home snuck it into the
driveway i retrace my steps going back
through the gravel path and in through
the sliding door which i had left
unlocked sneak up to my room and i just
look at the note that i wrote and it was
the stupidest note because it said like
dad comma
i know you're probably worried about me
but don't be
i snuck out to go see
smithers at the movie theater i know you
probably think less of me for this but
just know that i did it for love
signed
i think i wrote sincerely
mark i love a vignette of your dad like
he hears the car driving away and like
peeks out the window stealthily as
you're driving away and it's like oh no
he didn't
and then just goes to your room and
picks up the letter and it's just
they're reading it like oh
oh no i don't think less of you at all
son
you go get smithers
oh that's my boy and he just like puts
the note back and is like well just
pretend it's fine
[Music]